What's up Marvel fans?
I am here with Benedict Wong.
How are you?
Hello, hello.
Ecstatic, excited, bit tired.
Bleary eyed from
five AM work call.
But as soon as I get in there--
Well, these are waking
me up as well, actually.
Oh, it's just fizzing
with excitement, you know?
It's an exciting
time to be here.
So you've been busy.
Wong has been very
busy in Marvel Studios'
Shang-Chi the Legend
of the Ten Rings, now
Spider-Man No Way Home.
And not to mention
your upcoming film,
Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness.
There's a lot weighing
on Wong's shoulders,
how's he handling it?
I'm OK, with aplomb.
I got an email from Kevin
Feige saying it's fast becoming
the WCU, so I'll take that.
So here we are.
The Wong Cinematic Universe.
I like it.
I like it, definitely.
What is it like to
get a chance to dive
into the Marvel multiverse with
all the weird creative worlds
that it entails?
Well we'll certainly have
to do a lot of versions.
And it's also filming as
well, during this time as well
where we're kind of like--
You know, if something
happens then we hit plan B,
we hit plan C. So we're kind
of living in a sort of quantum
filming schedule.
You know, so it's been.
That must be
crazy as an actor.
Yeah.
I mean, I call it "The Madness
of the Multi Schedule."
That's it, really.
You know, Doctor Strange that.
Well, before you
leave, what's something
that you can tell us that
the fans can look forward to?
Maybe a little tease.
Uh, [LAUGHS] Well, you
know, there'll be a shift,
I think, definitely
in this which will,
hopefully, you know--
We'll see different
responsibilities I think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]